hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
relative [ __ ] making ethics and also in
a number of his other where we can call
ethnic Oh political works so we're
talking about gaming ethics the rhetoric
politics the poetics and several other
works
your son will use this Greek term which
is a little bit difficult to translate
pro hire ASIS and it's coming from the
you know prefix Pro which means in place
of or in front of and right hydrate
which means to grab or to seize right so
a pro a racist means almost literally
taking one thing in front of or instead
of another as Aristotle will discuss at
several different points and why is this
term so important well because virtue
and vice what we're praised for or
blamed for is in large part a matter of
choice it's not just a matter of the
actions or emotions themselves a person
is evaluated on the basis of the choices
and we might say commitments that they
make now one of the things that I want
to signal as we look at the nikah
mechanics book three treatment which is
not
only discussion of prior ASIS that they
are so yes but a very important one is
that although Aristotle is not
distinguishing this he's just talking
about these in a way that shows you that
these are two different consumptions
choice means not only individual choices
made in specific situations like
choosing to shoot a video rather than to
lay around and do nothing all day right
that's an that's an individual choice
it also means patterns larger scale
running through time patterns of choice
they have form us into the kinds of
people that they are am I the kind of
person who typically chooses to shoot
the videos that I pledged I would do or
am I the sort to say oh that will happen
another day it'll take care of itself
let me take a nap right those are our
two lists there's an individual choice
being made there in the situation but it
could be part of a larger pattern of
choice Aristotle has both of these
meanings in mind when he's talking about
the term sometimes in some passages it's
clearly about individual choice and some
other passages it's clearly about
patterns of choice but the two of them
form each other so it's important to
keep that in mind
now he says how can we define it or
characterize it so one of the things
that he says is if we understand what
the class of the voluntary is things
that people are responsible for we can
say choice is something voluntary it
falls within that scope but it's
narrower because not everything that's
voluntary is chosen there is more to the
act of choice than simply being the
initiator of the the action so you can
say like I put here not everything
that's volunteer is chosen but
everything that is chosen is indeed
voluntary the the chosen or choice is a
subclass of what is voluntary and that
covers a lot for Aristotle now he spends
quite
telling us what it is not and you might
say well that's not particularly helpful
to cheat I want to know what it is not
what it is not
what are you doing something sort of
chipping away at some misconceptions
that we might have so we should take a
look at some of these these discussions
he says choice it is a type of desire or
Raxus or if we want to use an even
broader term because desire makes us
always think of like heading towards
something the way aristotle uses or axis
it includes all affective 'ti so it
includes all of our feelings all of our
emotions our desires our aversions all
of that falls within the scope of our
axis or or desire Aristotle is going
insane then it's not this or this or
this why does he talk about those well
in other places he will break desire
down into three main categories leaving
out of course prior racist and and some
of the other things appetite or apathy
Mia what we translate here is anger
although it's a bit broader than than
the emotion of anger through most is the
spirited part of our ourselves and wish
or rational desire blazes and he'll tell
us more about those at different points
that we will certainly talk about those
in other videos now why is why is Pro
racist not any of these things well
let's take a look at what he actually
says he says the irrational animals
don't exercise choice but they do feel
desire they feel appetite some of the
children too by the way and children
also feel anger in that sense that rival
risks bunch of emotions you know so it
can't be those because if it was those
then children and animals wouldn't
happen right so as Army says also a man
of defective self restraint as we'll
look here they acts from desire but not
from choice now the country assault for
straying
Ashville choice and not from desire a
point that will hit on the gap a little
bit later they says desire can run
coverages desired meaning appetite but
not appetite to appetite and appetite he
has regard to an object as pleasant or
painful
whereas choice doesn't necessarily do
that choice is about a different range
of values which include things like the
noble and the base the useful and the
harmful the just and the unjust these
these moral categories or values that
aerosol effects help Pelton fill out the
scope of the good so it's not appetite
one of them is it not anger he says or
passion or spiritedness
he says well these accidents is not much
of an explanation
these attacks seem something very
different from the acts done on
deliberate choice why because anger kind
of gets away from us right there is
actually a reasoning process involved in
anger is there a Sowell understands he
talks about this in book seven anger is
like a hasty servant who who you know
perceiving that some sort of insult or
injury has been given immediately rushes
off without listening to the directions
and you know aims at revenge or
retaliation so then Aristotle thinks in
itself is not really that related to
choice we haven't be able to be careful
with that
because prior ASIS will play into the
virtues and vice devices associated with
anger as it will with with that a
concern with appetite namely temperance
but it's not the same thing as that
desire what about a rational desire or
wish so here's something talks about
this in a little bit great of length he
says they seem closely connected but
here's some differences choice Pro
racist cannot have as its
in possibilities we don't choose things
that we know in fact the impossibilities
but we do here and for things that are
for us impossibilities he says for
example if a man were to say that it
shows something impossible would be
thought to be a fool we did wish for
things that are impossible for example
in mortality we can't choose now there's
in Aristotle's context I understand that
some religious people might say yes we
can choose immortality or that there's
something like that aerosol is not
working in that context for the ancient
Greeks a human being it can't choose
divine immortality but we can certainly
yearn for that or wish for it he says
also we may wish for what cannot be
secured by our own agency for example a
particular actor an athlete may win
right we have all sorts of wishes about
that for example I think about sports
teams people get all sorts of an
emotional investment in my team I hope
they've men I hope they go to the
championship we control that's not a
matter of our shoelaces that put them
there if the choices of those those
athletes out there and I suppose the
coaches and other people as well
including the teams that they're playing
against that decides that it's not our
our choice so the choice is not a matter
of wish and he says this is even more
important we wish for ends rather than
for means but choose the means to our
end for example we wish to be healthy
but we choose things that will make us
healthy so we have wishes in play and
then we use choice to get ourselves
there or or perhaps if we choose badly
to not get ourselves there because we
choose something else instead
what kind of desire is it that well the
Aristotle will call it at several points
in this book and in other books as well
curd for example in book six he will
call choice deliberative desire what is
a deliberative desire
because it engages and involves some
deliberation about the means to desired
ends the ends are given to us by wish or
my other other things and immoral
principles but we we choose the means
that will get us to those ends when we
first think about or reason about or at
least go through some sort of implicit
process of practical reasoning what
would actually get us there given that
we have these desires for these ends
what will allow us to implement those
desires choice isn't just a matter of
deliberation because it leads to action
that goes beyond merely deliberating and
it's a designer that is you know
supposed to be effective in leading to
some sort of action we mean I can't what
it is that we want if there's outside
factors that intervene but all of the
things being equal you know we should
now I want to go back to this point that
came up in terms of not being appetite
Arizona will say that the self-control
person we're gonna do some videos on
that as well but that's discussed in
book seven the self-control person
follows choice one of they follow a
choice against against there are other
kinds of desire for example they can be
self controlled in the full sense in
relation to appetites desire for
physical pleasures they might also be
self controlled with respect to their
anger response they follow their choice
against what it is that their desire is
telling them to so we really have two
kinds of or axis or F activity warring
against each other one of them is
rational and the other one is irrational
and the self-control person follows the
rational not so with the person who is
uncontrolled a crack in that case they
follow desire against what they've
chosen to be the right thing so they
made a choice but then they don't follow
through on that choice this is why you
know probably racist might well be
translated
not just as choice but as commitment
when a person goes against their
commitments what they know they want to
be doing they are as we say uncontrolled
or lacking self-control or a crowd no
another important point that I didn't
put up here
another thing that choice is not aerosol
says is opinion opinion is something
that we judge or we think about things
choice is something that has to do with
activity and do it so they may run
parallel with each other and we may
indeed have opinions that lead us to
desires or our opinions may be
reflective of our desires you know when
we desire something we have an opinion
that it's a good thing for us and we
should pursue it but the choice and
opinion are not exactly the same thing
although they may run in parallel this
leads us to the last point which is that
choice as Aristotle status determines
our character whether it is good or bad
whether we are good people or bad people
ultimately depends on the choices that
we make you know so if we don't engage
for example in any sort of deliberation
we're probably going to make really bad
choices there's a lot of things that you
know get pulled into to the fabric of
prior races and this is part of why
primary races can't just be a matter of
individual choices made situation a
situation but also the larger patterns
of choices that are put together by lots
of individual choices it's got a bit of
an ambiguity in the term it has both of
these senses at the same time in this
this passage in nikka Makino ethics book
3